[Music]
you don't have to jump over there it's
like a little Bailey bud hey guys yeah
people have told us that they were like
missing seeing Pookie everyday so I said
well we could do a sidetrack stick cuz
we have a couple things to talk about
and as soon as we like both sat in here
and start recording she was like I said
hey poke you want to stick your butt in
the camera just for old times sake and
you did exactly that
that's her back bellybutton kitty look
how bright that light in the background
is which one that one of the blue ones
is like white are you seeing that oh
it's right here right here but look how
white it is like on the that's weird
yeah we got two we got two more lights
well I think they're coming tomorrow so
everything's all [ __ ] up in my yeah it
wasn't before yeah the weird thing is
like we so we got these lights and like
some of them if you you like put it on
the color and the brightness that you
want and they stay there like when you
turn them off or unplug them or whatever
but then there are two of them that
every time you turn it on it goes back
to like a different like a default color
I'm not sure why it's there all the same
brand yeah I got it I got it take it in
another room there's little remotes for
it there must be something I have to do
yeah probably because this one over here
it's like we have it like set to kind of
like a pinkish red color but every time
like I unplug it and plug it back in or
turn it back on it goes back to like
magenta which is very strange and then
the other ones don't really do that so
she just comes running she's like you
can't shut me out pal she comes in like
she's coming in the [ __ ] bar or
whatever so the reason I wanted to do
with sidetracks today was because we saw
like a really good movie last night and
it was one of those ones that kind of
fell into that gray area between not new
enough for matinee and not old enough
for retrospective but I still wanted to
kind of talk about it so I said well
[ __ ] it we'll just do like a sidetrack
show I guess about it and
so shudder just added it it's called
turbo kids yeah it was awesome
turbo kit in the movie is about four or
five years old already yeah I think it
came out well the the copyright on the
end said 2014 but I think it was
released in 2015
yeah it's a Canadian movie The Canadian
New Zealand yeah it's got some 2p from
New Zealand in it and it's a it's a fake
80s movie yeah
it's a post-apocalyptic superhero movie
it's not super super gory yes super
super gory and super funny very
good-hearted there wasn't it's very 80s
themed it had 80s [ __ ] soundtrack it
even had like heavy metal like a power
ballad yeah I'm like hilarious yes
survivor so yeah yeah everything is
meant to [ __ ] be from that genre but
they're using modern technology and this
is kind of what they wanted an 80s movie
low budget movie to look like back in
the 80s but they couldn't do it you know
I mean but with technology now you can
make you can make that 80s tone the way
they really wanted it to look back then
yeah did but we couldn't do it you know
we didn't have you didn't have it but
even the special effects are kind of
like even though they're a lot better
than to had in the 80s they were 80s
style
yeah yeah I mean they didn't look
realistic right look like some amount of
Power Rangers but they did but you could
tell that they did that on purpose yes
they were trying to get a particular
aesthetic yeah
about it but it's like I love that
[ __ ] conceit of this movie which is
like we started watch like shudder just
added it and you know I don't know if
you don't have shudder they have instead
of like star ratings they have little
skulls so this one had like five skulls
and not a lot of movies have that then
like a couple of old John Carpenter ones
that stuff so I was like okay well
that's a recommendation so we started
watching it and immediately like when
that power ballad k-much like okay there
we were like okay I see where this is
going and and this ended up being like
so it it Amash like so many movies from
back then it was particularly cherry
2000 like a lot is very cherry 2000 or
similar yeah it's kind of it
set in 1997 but it's an alternate 1997
it's it's as though like the apocalypse
happened in the 80s and now it's 1997
because I guess because a lot of movies
that were saying it's like 1997 but it
also washes it also Amash is [ __ ]
fallout yes she's got basically a
pip-boy yeah and some of the technology
is way beyond what you could get in the
80s it was eighties fantasy technology
yeah so you know me but it was pretty
cool is it's a boy meets girl story the
boy in Apocalypse meets this super cute
girl who's like yeah she she's been
alone on her own I don't want to [ __ ]
spoil it like she's weird but yeah she's
weird but it all makes sense but it was
later she's like on her own for a long
time she's really trying to please him
you know Namine and [ __ ] be his
friend and he doesn't really want a beer
for is he doesn't trust her you know but
it takes it takes time for him to get to
know her and then there's bad guys and
then there's another guy who's kind of
like a crossing a cowboy and Indiana
Jones it's his buddy and it's got
Michael Ironside as the villain and he
Ironsides the [ __ ] out of this they told
him to they told him to set the ire side
setting on [ __ ] you 1111 you tell you
was having a lot of fun with the [ __ ]
movie the Gores off the charts it was
good though I loved it was funny it was
funny this is like some Peter Jackson
Dead Alive kind of [ __ ] they were happen
in this some of the gore gags in this we
were just dying we're yeah cracking up
so hard like they're super gross but
they're like super creative and yeah
honey so they're taking the
post-apocalyptic theme and then mixing
it with superhero and [ __ ] fallout
and in this [ __ ] awesome I was just
in it for you know I was a few minutes
into it and I was going like I'm getting
kind of like this is the vibe that
sherry mm wanted yeah if you guys never
seen that one that one's pretty good too
I think it's free on YouTube you know -
yeah it's a it's got Melanie Griffith in
it and it's a
it's it's cheap but yeah it does have
its moments though it does have some
good it's funny too you know it's it's
kind of but I have to say I liked this a
lot better this is lot better I like
cherry 2005 act might one of my brothers
old punk bands back in the 80s was a or
80s or 90s was the name cherry too
though because he really liked that
movie but uh I you know we just watched
cherry 2000 probably what like a month
ago something like that cuz like I said
it's free on YouTube and I liked it but
this one was a lot better because I
don't know that there was something just
really really endearing yeah about this
maybe like about the characters and
about like the relationships with one
another and I just really liked and they
were amazing the 80s without being super
obvious but I like that you know they
emerged like army of Darkness they some
other things but without being too like
wink wink a look at what we're a moshing
type of thing like it just seemed very
pure hearted the movie is what the movie
you wanted to see back then when you
were like 10 but they did they never
made it yeah they're like between a 10
and 18 although you know I mean I could
have watched this [ __ ] at when I enjoyed
it at my age you don't I mean but I
would at 20 out of [ __ ] loved it and
I think you're right I think I had a lot
to had to do with the tone of the movie
it's a fun tone the the relationship
between all the characters as [ __ ]
like everything's like normal kind of
normal sweet you know I mean yeah but
yeah that's a good way to put it you
don't I mean although there's villains
you know they're [ __ ] doing fun that
are that are doing really [ __ ] up but
like this boy girl dynamic is very
[ __ ] kind of like it's lacking
nowadays in movies you know what I mean
I don't like any of that [ __ ] weird
like I don't know weird kind of forced
cultural Marxism or intersectional ISM
or any that I just like just wait normal
people are regular people are and this
is just like regular people
to me although it is a fantasy ya know
but it's kind of like you know the main
[ __ ] it was it's kind of like a
relationship that [ __ ] teenagers
would would [ __ ] love to have it's
but it seems like you know I mean to be
yeah and I think like the you know the
awkwardness between them and like you're
being like super weird and like
seemingly like really aggressive with
her friendliness and he's like doesn't
know what to do with that yeah he's like
the wastelands kind of thing yeah and
he's in his apocalyptic bunker you know
what I mean [ __ ] trying to be a man
make it on his own
well I see what's making it he was make
it on his own it's like I didn't want
her tagging along it out of it he had
like a little man cave damn yeah my
stuff like halts these toys and comic
books and stuff like that because he was
like brilliant again yeah she saw his
his ass up though well not well not
really it might be she kind of hardens
is that sub-2 with that - yeah well you
know he he has to man up yeah I mean and
you know he puts he puts himself out
there for I don't want to spoil the
movie
yeah don't and like I said now even
though this is like a really sweet
charming like 80s throwback is a lot of
fun it's not for kids it's like super
super violent and really really gory
like I said think like you know Peter
jelly curly Peter Jackson type of not
quite that gross but like really really
bloody there's a lot of like beheadings
you know sob lis it's like [ __ ] arms
flying and [ __ ] like that time I'm
looking at the girl names Apple yeah and
it's like winneth Paltrow yeah I'm
looking at her she looks familiar
and at the end towards the in a moment
JD she looks for [ __ ] [ __ ] familiar
Jew that looks just like Britney we got
a friend like in the face yeah yeah
Britney's prob about a foot taller
though yeah cuz this girl well this
girl's probably like average height
Britney's like pretty tall I think yeah
I think that girl's 5 - but yeah the
second I saw her I was like oh my god
that looks just like Britney but I
didn't say anything but like him later
out of the movie when you said hey this
she looks pretty might be about five
eight you know though we only see your
nose big s yeah I don't ever see her
barefoot yeah because I think people
think I'm a lot taller than I am because
I always wore like big platform but it
said I'm only like 5 foot yeah it's hard
to say it's hard to say but yeah so
movie though is and it's like amazing
that I hadn't heard of it because like I
said I guess it came out in 2015 and I
guess it played it like South by
Southwest and it got like I think it's
got like 90 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
and so it's got like really good reviews
and stuff and they were even talking
about like making a
sequel yeah well no it's got okay
they're making it yeah so that's what
I'm thinking this script and everything
ounce that back in 2016 this the last I
heard that they have a script and
everything they want to do it they're
looking for backers but I think they
said they had they had some people that
were interested we'll just have to wait
and said yeah I don't know the guy who
made this movie was just got off of
making something else yeah cuz I think
it was three writer directors and I
think they're they're from Quebec I
think yeah and I'm not sure if that's
where they shot this so like I said
there was it was partial sequel with the
sequel will pretty much directly homage
Mad Max yeah so it needs more money so
there's gonna be yeah I can say that
what they did in this one instead of
having cars they did what you would
probably actually really do in the
epochal which is they all had BMX BMX
bikes gasoline which like I said that's
that's very like you know
budget-conscious for the movie but also
real realistic because made heavy thing
several years after the apocalypse it
would be a team is you'll so you can't
use cars or anything like that unless
you figure out how to make cars or not
water or some [ __ ] so it's like seems
better I don't know it's just using a
bike seems better all around they're
quiet you can't defeat it you don't have
to feed it you feed themselves right
it's like you know I mean it just seems
like yeah it's a little bit slower but
it's better than walking and everybody
won't they had whole chase scenes on
them because that's all it's not like
you had to go faster you fast because
that's everything everybody had that's
fast enough
oh yeah do you just had your own legs
and you just have to like be faster than
the other chicks a trick they'd be
[ __ ] riding for their life being
chased place man she's been there
smiling smile oh oh and like I said it's
like you don't really know like I said
I'm not gonna spoil anything the fairies
are reason like why she's so weird like
cuz she comes off like really weird and
you're like what the hell is her deal
you know not we're in a bad way but like
weird and the wife says but there is a
reason so you don't find out so later
but yeah it's like it's just kind of
popped up on shudder and I was like that
sounds funny yeah I want to own this one
i'ma buy some home yeah this is a really
good one I really liked it a lot so um
what else has been going on in the last
few days because we haven't done
we haven't done a sidetracks and Hong
Kong Hong Kong got snapped up by [ __ ]
China I told you guys I told you guys I
told you guys we're gonna end up in a
cold war with China I don't think it'll
go hot but China's gonna be the next
Soviet Union it's swallowing up
countries next it's gonna try to swallow
up two I want yeah I told you guys I
keep my eye on this [ __ ] I a lot of
people are kind of innocent and they
just you know I mean they live in a
world they want to live in they don't
want they're not living in a world that
really is they don't understand the
[ __ ] evil yeah I mean I understand
evil you know I got a doctorate in it
I'm like dr. evil yeah 1 million
sometimes they want if you can take some
[ __ ] you just dare you know there are
there are people in here that we just
will you know and the whole
organizations and the CCP is like that
it's like a [ __ ] criminal
organization it's like communist bandits
that's what it does that's what they are
they take things man just like Soviet
Union they just [ __ ] take [ __ ] and
it's gonna lead to trouble speaking of
evil I got an email from one of our
patrons Dean today asking us if I had
heard about this particular guy that
went on a rampage and crime spree up in
Nova Scotia wasn't that long ago it was
only about a month ago like end of April
this [ __ ] dude um I can't like
remember what his name was but um that
actually the the Prime Minister of
Canada was like let's not like get his
name out there because we don't want to
make oh my god yeah that guy yeah it's
like I hadn't heard about that but like
I went to the Wikipedia page I wrote
what a [ __ ] lunatic I mean this guy
was like the same guy that you know we
were talking about on that on the review
of tread yeah like this guy was similar
to that except way way way more
destructive because this guy actually
did end up killing like 22 people or
something like that like he just goes
around it all apparently because he was
kind of a dick before that because
people said yeah he used to dress up as
a cop and like cosplay and stuff and
also I think that he had also gotten in
trouble for like beating up his wife at
some point so he has so him and his wife
and an argument of this party and then
he just like [ __ ]
went off the [ __ ] deep end he'd like
handcuffed her in the house like she
managed to get away he sets his own
house on fire and then he goes on this
[ __ ] rampage and he just goes around
shooting well at first he goes around
shooting people that he kind of knew
that I guess he thought were conspiring
against him or something he's like yeah
people he didn't like so he goes and
shoots a bunch of people sets their
houses on fire and then like as the you
know it because it was like a one or two
day spree and then he just starts
shooting like shooting random people
like just kind of breaking into people's
houses and shooting him and [ __ ] sit
in their house on fire and [ __ ] like
that
I shouldn't have [ __ ] with him I told
him don't [ __ ] would that dude so so
it's okay I told them about the [ __ ]
with that guy
well at least they shot him and he's
dead and flying with him well that's the
thing bullies and this is the same thing
that it's like that dude on trend it's
like no one was [ __ ] with them I
don't think yeah it's like you know at
least not to the extent that he thought
they were and it's like everybody gets
[ __ ] with deal with it dude the dude
blue yeah it's like it's just so that's
like really scary to think that like
people like that or just [ __ ] one
little atom away from like they just
have one fight with their wife and all
of a sudden start [ __ ] killing
everybody like [ __ ] settle down
settle down there's a lot of people in
the world I know a lot of them I know
and there's always gonna be a percentage
of them that are [ __ ] nuts yeah no
[ __ ] and then if you look at what's
happening in the world
you know new paradigms are changing and
things are [ __ ] falling apart and
[ __ ] you know even institutions that
people grew up believing in or being
[ __ ] unveiled us being [ __ ]
scamp's and people aren't happy and
everything's totally polarized and this
will continue it's just this isn't the
end this is the beginning this is just
how history works I'm telling you those
those borders on those maps they're
gonna change well but it's like that's
the thing it's you really have to you
have to understand that like just change
is inevitable whether you like it or not
and it's like there's not a lot you can
do about it it's like I'm not saying
that you just be complexity complacent
it roll over
and stuff but you really have to learn
to deal with things without like
flipping out and killing people yes you
did
just [ __ ] yeah but you also have to
deal with other people killing people
too well yeah I know everybody has
that's what that's what I this is the
[ __ ] we don't live in an idealized world
you know people are bad you know in
general I think they're just bad and
what makes them bad is that they don't
agree you know everybody believes in
something different then you got a lot
of them packed into one area and they're
gonna [ __ ] disagree over [ __ ] and
then no matter who you are you're always
gonna think that somebody you disagree
with this bad or evil you know I mean
that they have to be punished it doesn't
matter everybody thinks that and they
start fighting and then they start
fighting for what they believe is right
and you know that's how new countries
are formed that's how it falls apart
that's how civilizations rise and fall
it's just way people are that's why
that's why the elites want to do what
they did on Blade Runner just get rid of
us they want to replace those robots
that's what I like I I read the
Wikipedia page about that guy and then
like I just wrote back to back to Dean
and I was like you know it's like every
day I wake up and hope that humanity is
not gonna disappoint me but yeah you
know I've never had that happen you're
tripping I was like you know what I mean
it's well you know it's you try to be
like optimistic but you can't be I was
like maybe someday I'll be able to move
to the moon it'll be nice and quiet I
think the thing is just where we're
raised and were instructed and taught
certain things in school that are kind
of not that turn out not to be true
the concept of progress all right
there's a slight progress but it's not
progress like you think it progresses
towards something that you didn't want
it to progress towards as well well the
thing about it is not always it's like
you I I think the the myth is that
things progressively get better which
some things do but some things don't
don't
oh please don't please don't please kids
go step on a damn step on the thing
while I'm trying to and not you know so
I think technology will continue to kind
of
but that doesn't necessarily mean
society will progress towards well it
all depends on what you believe progress
is you know I mean you have some people
that believe that the height the
progress is what's written in [ __ ]
the Quran and the hadith in this in the
Sunnah yet I mean I don't think that
that's progress but they do you know and
that's just an example everybody has
their own opinion of what they think
progress is it's you know that's where
the program that's where the problem
comes from yeah I mean like I said if
you know you can't think like you know I
I look back like a hundred years in like
that I'm like well obviously things are
like light years better than they were
back then I would not want to go back
then which is how I [ __ ] you know we
judge that kind of [ __ ]
but it's temporary though well
everything is like history goes up and
down and up and down and up and down
it's just you can't depend on any of
this well yeah it's just temporary well
that's why I try not to get too upset
like I said I'm not gonna like flip out
and like shoot a bunch of random people
just because somebody made me mad about
something that's dumb I mean you know
you could scroll forward 300 years and
then you'd find here on the American
continent maybe four countries and
there'd be something if three of them
say did [ __ ] like didn't allow women to
vote or some of them had reinstituted
[ __ ] room slavery but this time white
people are the slaves
nothing [ __ ] stays the same it's
changing constantly yeah well like I
said if you look at the Iranians you
know over in Persia you know they have a
long long history and they had a long
history of [ __ ] ethnic groups within
Persia [ __ ] overthrowing one another
and subjugating one another over and
over again that's kind of the way humans
are I know yeah so I don't know keep
doing the same stupid [ __ ] yeah I don't
have faith that's what I mean by being
constantly disappointed in you always
expect you always want them to do
something yeah I don't have any of these
delusions yeah another man [ __ ] do I
like I know it's [ __ ] up and it's
gonna continue to remain [ __ ] up and
it might get even more [ __ ] up the
only thing you can do is
just keep your [ __ ] [ __ ] wired tight
and [ __ ] do with it as it comes
chances are it takes a long time you'll
be dead before it really gets bad yeah
that's what I think for civilizations to
collapse and fall and divide new
countries before them back in the old
days that that took decades decades and
decades you know I mean you just look
like having to roam that took a long
time Rome declined and fell for about
150 years yeah didn't happen overnight
that's true and this is looking a lot
like that diseases Wars Foreign Wars
[ __ ] revolts breakaway republics
although like I said you could argue
that that's an ongoing well yes I'm
saying this is not unusual this is an
ongoing process it's always like this
yeah well there's kitty but again we had
their good times and bad times it's
mostly bad times well you know it's you
if you stand back and look at it it
might be a good time for you cuz you
might be getting something out of it at
that moment yeah you know there's so
there's the first person and third
person views on this well yeah like I
said I mean and there's only so much as
you know everybody is just one person
there's only so much [ __ ] so like you
know third person might say the Great
Depression was a terrible time but for
some people first-person view of that
they were [ __ ] making money hand over
fist and nobody else had any money so
they could buy everything up cheap they
were the big man on [ __ ] block yeah
so you know there are some people that
look back and you know look back you
know with I wish it is back in the old
depression yeah those guys are all dead
now but you know there were guys that
actually [ __ ] made [ __ ] whole
empires well yeah everybody I mean you
know as shitty as things are for most
people it's like there's always gonna be
somebody of it yeah thanks man they're
taking advantage of it yeah I've just
learned not to [ __ ] trust anything
and not to believe in anything other
than myself my you know I mean I know I
can make it yeah I have to and if I get
killed it's okay there's nothing to
worry about
you die it's over quick well yeah
because one was a force of [ __ ] he's
gonna come back as a force ghost with a
[ __ ] I wouldn't you read me
that's what I mean I don't know what you
know I'm just coming back and haunt and
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I don't think I
can't think of anybody that I would
haunt be like going back a bit ahead
would be like going back yard I was
gonna say her going back to high school
and yeah why would you want to do that
that was lucky I don't know maybe I
maybe I can think of somebody that I
could haunt for a little while but
probably it wouldn't be that probably
because I'm sure I'd have better things
to do
all right so uh you you done talking
yeah just trying to make content people
you know just just talking yeah Tomica
Mountain
like I said I said I told you guys we're
still gonna do side tractions it's not
gonna do them every day and like I said
just because we saw turbo kid last night
now I was like oh I guess we could talk
about that throwing out food for thought
I'm gonna back watch these riots I'm
gonna see if there's a riot going on
over there that dude [ __ ] do you see
that you hear about that no I've been
working
oh man they had the second car they had
these cops here arresting this black
dude for some stupid it was like forgery
or something I forward and he's kneeling
on the [ __ ] dudes neck they got a
video of it he's gonna I can't breathe
get off and and and the dude [ __ ]
killed him now I don't know that's in a
lot of law enforcement manuals it's a
way of knocking somebody out yeah I know
which man that looks awful [ __ ]
illegal if you ask me yes
but it's legal though that doesn't mean
it shouldn't be I don't think they
should be able to do that I know you
know maybe in extreme cases but the dude
didn't seem like he was struggling I
didn't see the whole thing I just saw
where the video started he was already
on the ground anyway that dude died well
there's a lot all right like to sit here
[ __ ] now loot and everything and uh
you know which is I think that's kind of
[ __ ] you're gonna mean you loot your
own [ __ ] neighborhood you know just
get some free [ __ ] why not just looking
you know I mean go demonstrate or
something you know everybody agrees that
that dude you know I mean was was
mishandled nobody disagrees with that
well yeah like they got that [ __ ] on
video that seems to happen alarmingly
often yeah you know what I mean like
they're not even struggling and it's
like yeah and if you looked at the cops
you know the men the cops don't get away
with it they always Darryl
I look at those cops and you know a
[ __ ] I worked for a company that
[ __ ] contracted for Louisiana State
Police and those are [ __ ] in low
quality [ __ ] cops I mean you know I
don't think it was damn I remember this
if not Philadelphia I don't even
remember the damn city but I just look
at the cops now I'm like man they look
like scumbags to me yeah
they didn't within like State Police
they look like maybe some kind of city
police so um just see how this [ __ ] goes
but I blame a lot on it on I blame a lot
of it on the [ __ ] tensions that what
happened with this pandemic people being
locked up for a long time you know and
[ __ ] is economic stresses and social
pressures well everyone's nerves are
free yeah and these [ __ ] cops went
off on this dude and you know I've run
into some [ __ ] cops they got some
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] cop we need to
just smoke some weed and calm down
it'll be okay yeah but even if it's not
okay it's like if you wait long enough
it'll be okay again so you might as well
just chill the [ __ ] out just have some
weed have some cake just calm down
nothing anybody can do about it not
really
yeah it's it's [ __ ] bad what the way
shit's going shit's [ __ ] falling
apart it looks like we'll see
although [ __ ] like this went down in the
60s too
that's what I mean although that [ __ ]
fell apart in the sixties though - yeah
but it's like not for ever yeah you know
well Detroit never really came back yeah
but that's just that's one city out of
like a huge you know what are you gonna
do those riots there was like the
equivalent of like a bomb on you just
gotta roll [ __ ]
this uncertain future futures are always
always that sir
yeah it's true you could walk outside
and get hypnotized tomorrow
your future is always uncertain I'm just
gonna see what you know I'm gonna see
what happens man you know we need to do
we need to like start working more on
this [ __ ] cookbook man yeah well you
told me you were gonna start like what I
told him to do was because he's not
gonna write down like how he does stuff
so I told him aren't you just record
yourself talking about and I'll write it
down
so I told you to do that okay I have
like um sort of uh I have to kind of get
together and do it that's what I mean I
have sort of um you know like a like a
rudimentary layout like I have an idea
of like how I want you to go but but
until you tell me like what all who's
gonna go in there we have a list like I
said we have like a huge rip when you're
when you're ready you can record me and
I'll go I'll walk you through it okay
that'll be good because then I can we
can just do do it section by section
yeah we'll just do like a few at a time
like probably because I put things into
sections
um the like American section or like um
you know you you know southern US
recipes that's gonna be by far the
biggest section that's where we had most
of the stuff and I think drinks and
desserts is the second biggest but then
you know then we're gonna do I'll
probably do like Asian and Indian like
all in one thing and then maybe like a
couple other sections you know cuz I'm
just trying to like think of like the
best way to put everything together and
it's gonna have like a [ __ ] index and
everything to do so people can like skip
through stuff but I wanted to start
doing because I really want to get that
done in like the next few months so
we're gonna have to like get on that
yeah I told you yeah okay yes she kind
of nagging me about I'm not nagging okay
I have to nag you or they'll never do
anything but you never come ask me [ __ ]
like cuz you're only two nights ago okay
ask you two nights ago I said I said hey
I need you to do something for me like
start recording yourself talking about
the recipes so I can start writing it
down because I can't really move forward
with it until I like know exact
she's laying on but she's going cheese
at all the time I know
well yeah see you oh you just admitted
it she does I say it all the time
yeah no I'm just saying I have to all
right so yeah what got up it got up at
5:30 in the morning yeah well I woke up
at 5:15 because I had to go to the
bathroom and then you must woke me up
and then you were like you because he's
like really he's a very noisy person
like if in case you couldn't tell
yeah he you can't even like stretch or
like turn over in bed without like I'm
like I'm trying okay see I'm usually saw
some of it I'm thinking some of it you
know I talked to myself in my sleep yeah
he does yeah yeah cuz sometimes things
in my sleep and all they all comment on
it and I'm glad you're dead [ __ ] yeah
that's the thing and I don't even know
if like that you looked up yeah I don't
even know if you're awake or now I mean
you know sometimes me talking about it
wakes me up yeah sometimes I'll hear and
be like I don't like that [ __ ] yeah I'm
like what don't you like conversations
with everybody and I'm seeing things and
people are showing me stuff yeah it's
not as bad as you used to be you see
you're like a lot worse like yes if I
can talk a lot more you sleep you still
do but not yeah but yeah alright so
that'll do it for this sidetrack we'll
probably do another one
Katie Rowan oh she's rolling yeah we'll
probably do another one this weekend I
think I have one more matinee that's
going up this week so I'll probably put
that up on Sunday but we'll probably do
another sidetrack on Saturday I'm
imagining alright so you guys have a
good rest of your Thursday and we'll
talk to you again later
[Music]